[Music]
[Music]
antarctica
[Music]
it's the least explored least understood
continent on earth
[Applause]
[Music]
in winter the sun never rises
in summer it never sets
5.4 million square miles of frozen
desert
home to the driest place on earth
[Music]
average winter temperature 20 to 90
below
barely anything can survive here
[Music]
no native people or land mammals
not even a single tree
but in spite of the worst conditions on
earth humanity
is working to scratch out a
is presence mummer of a bloody uh
confess
now we advance onwards into nothing just
ice shelf and horizon now
about to hit some ice race for shot
the world's top scientists they're
really cryptic
totally designed for living in this sea
ice and the men and women
who keep them alive oh we're just about
to enter into the shear zone here
join forces to battle conditions that
threaten human life
visibility's down to 20 meters
the coldest temperature ever recorded
135.8 degrees below zero
and the strongest ever sustained wind
199 miles per hour
all in the name of research that could
change the world
when's a pretty thick ice here
hey what just happened something that
just hit something
we've got the locks and somebody to
investigate it want to put the
proportions
antarctica is the last great mystery
on earth
in this frozen wasteland at the bottom
of the planet
it takes a massive effort just to
survive
there are over 70 bases built by 30
countries
and spread across the continent at the
mouth of mcmurdo sound
in the heart of the ross sea region is
scott base
new zealand's permanent research outpost
hey guys
here scientists are housed fed and
protected from the elements
by a network of green buildings linked
by weatherproof tunnels
and it's all coordinated by scott base
leadership
right now at scott base this is the busy
season and it starts in october
and it goes right all the way through to
february so that's five months that
we're
pretty much peaking in total we'll have
about 330 people going south
so it's pretty crazy it takes you know
over 200 people to support you know
90 scientists
get that one over up on top can help you
tie that stuff down
today the ross ice shelf team is leaving
on one of the most ambitious
expeditions in the history of scott base
we're packing up
all of our science cargo is ready to go
ten
scientists and two survival experts are
going 220 miles
south to a floating mass of ice attached
to the continent
where no one has likely ever set foot
the ross ice shelf is the largest lump
of floating ice in the world
it's the size of france and actually
we've got one
measurement that's ever been made in the
1970s
that's it and the rest of it's a mystery
so little is known
the surface of pluto has much better
imagery than what's beneath the ross ice
shelf
it's a lot of new stuff that we're going
to discover
dr christian owniser and his team are
hoping to learn how the ice shelf
reacted to climate shifts in the distant
past
so they can try to predict how fast it
might melt as the climate changes
in the future the ross ice shelf holds
back a piece of ice sheet that's treated
if it falls apart and it melts
even though it's far away the impact
would
be somewhere in the order of six seven
meters of sea level
but i'd be worried about 10 centimeters
that's already enough to
impact low-lying areas like where i come
from south dunedin
you can write off whole neighborhoods
there six metres of course you're wiping
out
everything we've got fire extinguishers
in all vehicles
i'll just go and double check that
they're in there
tom is in charge of team safety and he
has to lead them south across over 200
miles of rough ice
including a known area of deadly cracks
called the shear zone
the shear zone massive crevassing out
there they are
huge pretty humbling sights nobody has
to leave a vehicle during that that
time we go through that area some of the
crevasses in the shear zone can be five
six seven meters wide and probably 30 40
meters deep
so it really gives you that perspective
that we're quite a small fish in the in
the grand scheme of things and mother
nature really has control here
bringing the back one in the front
you're good to go
knowing that it's it's my responsibility
to make sure that everybody can get back
to scott bay safely it's a huge huge
deal
let's roll
to survive the journey the team is
relying on specialized vehicles
called hagmans these is pretty tough
they're tracked vehicles they share
similarities with tanks
really well suited for what we need them
to do
i'm looking at this wide expanse of
nothing and it's a bit creepy
we've spent so much energy and time
months of planning and building a piece
of equipment
but now what happens no one's ever done
this before it's exploration it's going
to be interesting
from this point on we've got four hours
before we get to the shear zone and
very gingerly make our way through
what's essentially a minefield of
crassus
[Music]
can only house 85 people at a time so
projects are constantly
cycling through there are more than 90
missions scheduled this season
none of them more challenging than this
one
hey graham danny do we have everything
we need
all the cables and coils and skis
they're all out there good the mount
arabis team is studying antarctica's
most active volcano
choppering to 132 different sites to
plant instruments that'll create a
composite image of its inner workings
oh those are stinky today they're
gearing up to fly near its summit
getting dressed to go about 11 000 feet
so it could be minus 20
up there and it's a rule that we always
have to wear this big puffy jacket and
the helicopter in case it crashes
another day double layer for comfort
and extra warmth dr graham hill is a
lead scientist for the project
we're measuring the electric field and
the magnetic field of the volcano
at a series of points which we then
combine
and do effectively a cat scan of the
subsurface
so if we can get a good understanding of
what the structure is
we have a better understanding of what
signals they might generate when they're
going to erupt
we'll be heading out and we can apply
what we learn about how this volcano
works to
other volcanoes elsewhere in the world
because quite a lot of people live
near volcanic centers so if they're up
they can just
wipe out the surrounding area volcanos
have a big impact on
human life let's get over there
time to go to work another day in
paradise
danny isn't a scientist he's a
world-class mountaineer
and it's his job to keep the team alive
on the side of the volcano let's go
i love doing my job i get to take people
on all these fantastic adventures
but you're not in control of the
environment either you're safe and you
come home or you screw up and you don't
come home
f flies the chopper mount erebus is just
more than 20 miles away
and he has to navigate unpredictable
winds
up here 20 knots maybe pretty good
he also has to find a safe place to land
and the whole mountain is covered
in crevasses
[Music]
basically your crevasse is like an
opening in the glacier like this
there's a lot of action in this area a
lot of movement in the glacier
oh look at that wow there's one mother
everybody uh called this
sometimes you can see right into them
and mean you go yep that's a crevasse
i'm not going to land in that big gaping
hole
but often it can be hidden underneath a
snow bridge
from the helicopter they could be in the
old size you know yeah something like
that
some people would think that we're a
little bit crazy to come to antarctica
and
fly around on a crevasse-filled volcano
that is erupting
you can see we're kind of out in the
middle of that ice stream there yeah
when you tell people these kind of
things back home they do look at you a
bit odd
why would you do that it's just one of
the realities of
actually doing the work all right one
more
is that looking we'll just find the
nicest looking spot
right in front of us that's great but
we're working with excellent pilots some
of the best in the world
we've got total faith in the guys that
we're flying with all right let's get
down to the
business end
[Music]
they've landed but they're not out of
the woods yet
just this year a veteran pilot from an
aussie base
landed on what appeared to be safe
ground he was delivering fuel to a depot
on the west ice shelf
but after getting out of his helicopter
he fell into a deep crevasse
they managed to retrieve him from a
depth of about 20 meters
but he died of his injuries
it's danny's job to check for crevasses
like that one
while the pilot keeps the rotor spinning
to take off quickly
if the snow caves in all right
uh the probes in the pod there it's in
your body
the mount erebus team's chopper is still
powered so it can lift off if a crevasse
opens up beneath him
i'll just go have a little poke and it's
danny's job to test for hard packed snow
and avoid hidden holes there's no doubt
in my mind that we're on terrain
that has crevasses underneath it we
can't see it is a pretty heavy
responsibility
i've had very close friends die in
crevasse falls
in situations just like what we're
dealing with here
so for me it's something that's very
real
okay
he's wearing skis to spread out his
weight
but even so every step is treacherous
it's kind of like this
walking between two skyscrapers
[Music]
at least the walker can see the drop
see the wire straight ahead
[Music]
crazy as it might be if he puts one foot
in front of the other
he'll make it safely across and avoid a
foot drop
danny could be over a similar drop and
he can't even see the wire
i'm just gonna poke around a bit
i have to poke around and really have a
good inspection of the site
kind of feeling in the snow for the
consistency and the snow depth
[Music]
hey guys i think it looks good to get
out it's a nice accumulation zone so
there's lots of snow here and
it's a nice compression area as well so
i think as long as we keep it nice and
tight we should be fine
you just have to have a little bit of
faith now it kind of blessed the area
this area is safe
and people can get out and start working
[Music]
graham and his team are on the clock
they have to bury
four sensors in four different
directions and run
hundreds of feet of cable back to a
central computer
and the chopper will be back for them in
two hours
fingers are getting a bit chilly trying
to do this out here in the wind i think
i've drunk too much water
ramen looks like you were hydrated good
job
in antarctica nothing gets left behind
not even urine in an effort to preserve
the most pristine
environment on the planet
[Music]
all human waste is brought back to scott
base
and every bit of it ends up here
after this comes out you know woman will
never look at me again don't you
paul is in charge of the water treatment
center better known as the poo plant
because there's so much influence at the
moment kind of it's easier on the system
to
just to do some manual stuff
our influence comes in through the main
sewer pipe and through the brush screen
brush screen takes out solid stuff and
that goes into
a bag so this is what we end up with out
of the sludge from the process
it's almost like beef jerky looking
wouldn't sell it in your local store but
there's a look of beef jiggy
the waste becomes scott base's primary
export
there's one good to go everything that
can't be recycled
is sent back to new zealand
it's part of a global effort to minimize
impact on the frozen continent
a goal of a treaty signed by 53 nations
you can't just have the waste from
people and everything happening here
just
disappearing into the into the ocean
it's uh
it's got to be treated it's got a we
could look after
just like the continent itself the
surrounding ocean
is carefully protected wildlife migrates
to these waters
every year and perhaps no feeding ground
is more important
than one off the coast of the antarctic
peninsula
the northernmost tip of the mainland
do you see in particular sites of
concentration back in here
if it's calm this is where those animals
will be sleeping oh nice
dr ari friedlander is one of the
preeminent scientists and
conservationists in his field
so there's something special about the
three or four areas right in here that
there's always whales
his goal is to study humpback and minky
whales
to find out how their ecosystem responds
to a changing climate this is sort of
right in the middle of that feeding
season so
filling that gap of what these animals
are doing at this time of year is going
to be pretty awesome
we're trying to measure the underwater
behavior and movements of the whales
get an estimate of their size and we're
trying to understand what whales need to
survive
and the amount of food that they eat if
you don't eat enough you're not going to
reproduce
if you don't reproduce it's a very quick
process and do your population not
growing
we just left deception highlanders so
we'll easily get into the galax straits
in the mouth of the herrera channel by
dawn
perfect if the whales are looking good
you can be out working
cool this is a place where people have
made huge changes in the environment
over the last 50 years the winter air
has raised
by about five degrees celsius the sea
ice over the last 30 years in this part
of the peninsula
has decreased in the number of days that
are ice covered
there's a huge standing stock of krill
here and that's what they need to feed
on
but the warming that's occurred here if
that affects the way that krill are
distributed
it could mean something pretty
significant
[Music]
more than 4 billion people rely on
seafood as a staple
and the fish we eat eat smaller fish
which eats smaller fish in some cases
all the way down the chain to this
krill as sea ice recedes the algae they
eat
goes with it and if krill disappears
so does the whale's food supply and a
big part of our own
we've got the drones and the suction cup
tags see if they survive the trip
we have a small uav a little quadcopter
with a camera on it
when we fly that over the whale we can
get a very precise estimate of the size
of that animal
so we're just going to fire the motors
up without the props to make sure that
it's all running
the other thing that we do is deploying
suction cup tags these tags they're
basically
like a smartphone they record the angle
of the whale
whether it's rolled over on its side the
heading of the whale the depth
and the speed of the whale and it does
that hundreds of times a second
it also records video which is awesome
because we can then
sort of corroborate the things that the
sensors are telling us with what we
actually see the whale doing
it's got two 720p cameras in there
we can get about nine hours of
continuous data and all of that
packaged together gives us a really
precise
uh estimate of the health of the animals
down here tag
data uav data combined is going to be
yeah opening new worlds really so let's
find some whales
yeah let's do it
the ross ice shelf team has traveled
about 30 miles
and they're facing the most dangerous
part of their traverse
oh we're just about to enter into the
shear zone here
we just want to make sure that
everybody's capable should the worst
possible case happen
the shear zone looks like a safe patch
of snow
but like mount erebus it's full of
hidden crevasses
for as flat and benign as it looks
there's a lot going on
one side we've got sort of the mcmurdo
um ice shelf and the other is the
roth ice shelf it's where two large
kind of ice masses are coming together
much like a river comes together
and the reason it's called a sheer zone
is because there's
kind of a shearing effect between the
two so it's quite an active
area interesting spot
the shear zone is an intimidating area
around about six or so kilometers
that have a number of significantly
large crevasses in them
we know that there's a route through
there we really reduce that speed down
even further so that we're 100 sure what
we're driving on is good to drive across
just keep a little extra following
distance how far do you want
to be maybe 50 meters we're just going
to be going a little bit
slower through here and if we stop
you should too we're just going to get
all our gear prepared for
crevasse rescue proceed with caution
fingers crossed crossing the sheer zone
should take a few hours
but tom and rob have been preparing for
it for weeks
so this is the radar boom for our pb 100
and we'll be fitting a gpr unit
ground penetrating radar and we'll be
able to see on the
monitor and when we're approaching
crevasses
and that'll enable us to not
drive into them state-of-the-art
technology real key piece of this whole
project
for this year and going into the future
as well so you
just got to get it up and running
the boom stretches 24 feet ahead and
connects to a screen that shows ice
composition
up to 49 feet deep bends in the lines
indicate empty space under the snow some
of the crevasses through here would
literally swallow this whole vehicle
and probably the two trailers behind it
um so
if we hadn't looked at the radar imagery
and we actually just carried on
dropped into a crevasse it would
probably be all over
okay team we're just gonna head off
slowly
aiming for about 12k an hour roger from
h1
roger
we've got some um black flags coming up
here tom
should be seeing something really
shortly i'd say
it's kind of creepy you know so each one
of these wooden stakes here represents
uh
a known crevasse right now we've got one
five meters that way
and one six meters that way
those black flames are a little
just along the whole road in the
crevasse area you see black flags
everywhere
black flags mean well death or don't go
there so that's a bit nerve-wracking
it is a bit spookier when you know you
know you're walking through the
alligator bit
and we believe this to be probably the
most dangerous area
hey guys we're about halfway through
you can see how this flag lines kind of
no longer straight
sort of indicative
yeah roger that that's crazy
wow there's so many crevasses here
we don't want to have any pets before we
even get the signs done
the largest crevasses ever measured on
the ross ice shelf
are almost 350 feet across and
500 feet deep and since the whole ice
shelf is floating
the cracks in it are constantly
a moving more black flags coming up they
look like reasonably new black flags
there's something coming in now pretty
high actually
the boom is about seven and a half
meters long and it gives us
around about three to six seconds of
stopping distance once we see something
come up on the screen
big big board going down and here's
something to be concerned about
stop that stop
walking is actually stopped now we just
stopped over
the ross ice shelf team is in the sheer
zone an area littered with deadly cracks
in the ice
and the lead vehicle is right on top of
one
obviously
[Music]
bridges uh are basically hiding the
crevasses so they're giving you a false
idea of what's beneath there so
driving along you can't actually see
that there's a crevasse down there
grab it and i'll run it around your side
and then you can clip on as well
just making sure that we've got
everything we need harnesses are
sitting correctly all the buckles and
loops are done up as they should be
uh we well and truly opened this up
[Music]
that's all that snow bridge that we
you're talking about
you can't quite see the bottom but it
goes down
at least 30 meters so yeah i'm just
going to try and prove this side here
rob and see how that looks for a
slightly better crossing yep
i've got through there
it's good
yeah so the crack's still here but it's
only maybe 15 or so centimeters wide
so it's obviously narrowing as we go
yeah that's looking real good from here
through here
[Music]
i'll bring up to bring them through this
way let's just watch them come across
and get them to park up before this next
post here
yeah and once they stop
then we'll go
all right guys we're just going to head
off
the slowly lines that tom made
over by the flags over there that's
going to be
where you guys are going to cross oh
roger thank you
it's actually quite scary doing this i'm
very nervous driving
you can fall down into a big hole and
you probably will die it happens it's
happened before in antarctica
but we can't turn back we'd spend so
much time planning
you just have to you just have to get
through that i mean that's what tom and
rob are there for getting coming a
little bit right now rob
bring it over towards me a little bit
please
stop
clear we're alive
well done should be good to go
let's get some kilometers under the belt
the team is safely across but now
scott base comms is monitoring a storm
heading up from the south pole
stop ice stop ice pb01
quite heavy snow okay
definitely a release to get through the
sheer zone but where we're driving to us
is pretty much directly south which is
where the storm system is going to come
in from
i guess you're always hoping it's not
going to be as bad as it's forecasted it
might blow out and we'll have fun
good reasonably good weather but years
worth of planning gone into these events
so
getting moving and seeing how it goes is
kind of part of
part of how it has to work down in
antarctica rob and tom have guided us
through
now we advance onwards into nothing wow
crazy just ice shelf and horizon now
[Music]
yeah i'm ready man three degrees to the
left of this little cloud
okay i'm going
i think we have to be a little bit more
minimal with the stopping
or else we're gonna get in trouble start
digging
the mount erebus team buries instruments
on a north south and east-west
axis to measure the naturally occurring
electric and magnetic fields that are
constantly passing through earth's
am i surface in a straight line it's
always the question
the currents move through different
layers of the earth at varying speeds
and a central computer records those
differences
their goal is to collect data across 132
different sites and combine them to
create a picture of the volcano's inner
structure
and magmaflow this little box is the
brains of the operation
out here is basically a
really really fancy data collector
and all of it has to happen before the
chopper comes back for them
it takes us about an hour and a half to
put one into the ground or if it's
a site where it's it's not
snow that you're trying to dig it's it's
glacial ice
it can take six seven hours so
you have to realize that things are
gonna take longer than they would
pretty much anywhere else in the world
it's been about an hour of sleep in the
last 36 hours for me
but that's a good hole
[Music]
so nick let's just have you right in
that spot there is good yeah i feel good
up here
and then we'll try and do it off
whichever side the animal gives
us ari is in a small inflatable boat
looking for a 66 000 pound humpback
whale
the frequency is 151.333
and he has to get close enough to attach
a suction mount to it with a 23 foot
metal pole
we're in wilhelmina bay one of the
locations that we've worked
in for a long time and we're going to
try and deploy
one of the video recording multi-sensor
tags on a humpback
let's see if we can uh see if that whale
is still there
[Music]
the whales come because the krill is
there when they're done feeding
they'll basically take a nap at the
surface
essentially look like a log for us it's
a great place because
the whales behave in a way that allows
us to approach them to put our tags on
i think i see something over there there
we go
right out in front of us off our bow
if that guy looks like he stops and logs
for a while we'll uh go up and approach
him
first approach always the best i'm going
gonna come either from five or seven
o'clock
and just try and get the tag on as high
up as possible is that cool yeah all
right
just stay whichever way we're going just
kind of stay on the opposite side
it's probably gonna be on the left side
of the zodiac
we're basically prepped up we're gonna
go sneak up on this guy go real slow
the key is to not wake them up as we
approach and not have them respond to us
so if we get up to it by the time it's
still logging we should be good
so you're gonna have to be full
extension for this guy yep
when we're approaching these whales it's
definitely a high risk kind of situation
if it's fluke hit the zodiac it would
flip us over without much
you know trouble you probably have five
or six minutes
in that water at the most before
hypothermia would set in
and it would be game over
[Music]
he's not gonna hear it
well now it's gonna die if the whale
responds to what you're doing
it's it's general response is gonna be
to dive
there he goes
sometimes we lose track of the whale and
we have no way of finding it
you might see a footprint in the water
from where kind of kicked away
uh but it's like one and done
this sucks
[Music]
i did see a whale i don't see a logging
whale now
i don't know where the one was that went
down here
ari and his team were close to deploying
a suction tag
but the whale they were chasing went
underwater
is that a logging whale out there can't
tell
no it's not these animals move over big
distances
very quickly they're real pain to work
with because they're difficult to find
you guys want to get the drone in the
air
this wouldn't be a bad spot yeah ari's
uav specialist
lars pilots a drone that can give them a
bird's-eye view
to help find a whale and give them more
information about it when they do
we can use this footage to look at body
size of these whales
typically we usually fly them in warmer
climates
this is the first time we've been in
antarctica flying in these colder
conditions
[Music]
is loyal working all right yeah it seems
to be fine
good how's your feed in this distance
it's good
what's that there it is
oh nice yeah that's good
oh he's got a buddy that's why he's kind
of fired up
we'll take one of our vessels within the
frame with the whale
that allows us to scale size of the
whale to the boat and that will allow us
to get us direct measurements
of how big the whale is
nicely done
sweet so nick it'll be no different if
the animal
is not um logging okay all right we'll
approach as slow as we can to still be
making up speed on it sure
[Music]
when we're approaching a whale human
safety is the first concern
[Music]
the thing you don't want to do when
you're approaching these animals is to
startle it
anywhere you can put it kind of
territory are you gonna
i'm gonna swing around don't worry it's
gonna be on our port side okay so we're
still going for it
if someone else wants to take the tiller
i'll tag okay
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice sweet nice dude
we're happy but the work is definitely
not over
the suction cup tags archive all the
data on them so we have to retrieve that
tag to get anything back
sweet there's the tag
[Music]
awesome
i think these animals have a lot more
going on than we understand or that we
have the
ability to be able to comprehend
holy
man
these animals get as curious about us as
we do about them
it's looking at you and it's it's kind
of wondering what you're doing there and
and we're asking the same kind of
questions lars correct me if i'm wrong
this is the first ever flight in the
antarctic right
for this equipment yes that's correct
couldn't ask for more
except for lars to buy us a couple of
drinks one big one
[Music]
out here every minute counts we've got
to really be efficient to get the job
done
[Music]
the mount erebus team has installed
three out of their four sensors
and run wiring back to the main computer
this one direction has definitely
changed and that cloud
not good at all
because that's coming up off the water
on the other side
but the same storm that's been
threatening the ross ice shelf team
is increasing the winds at high altitude
hey danny
have you noticed the change in weather
that cloud could lead to a camping trip
if the weather descends on us when the
helicopter is not around
you have your survival backs which have
tents and sleeping bags in case
you don't get home that night but you
don't want that to happen
scott bass from graham
yeah if you can get hold deshawn can you
tell them to rush out to get us right
now
roger
[Music]
ah how you doing me
how huh minutes do you think you'll make
sure you've done that uh we probably got
another six or seven minutes
there we go working now
oh yeah
[Music]
just pull around to the right a couple
hundred meters and uh
set up yeah
i'll pull up here guys and you can
come in nice and close behind us
the ross ice shelf team is now 40 miles
south of scott base
after a long day of driving they have no
choice but to stop
and rest but since they're the furthest
teams south
the worst of the storm could be just a
few hours away
all right so this is gonna be our home
for the night
so what we need to do is establish a
camp so
let's say this is our area here
prevailing wind's going to come in from
here
i like to have my camp kind of in a nice
neat line
going that makes sense
all right okay
we just want to get everything up and
get inside and get out of the wind
because it's cold
definitely fellas colder than it's got
base scott base is going to feel
tropical compared to this out here
once the storm hits these scott polar
tents will be their only protection
home sweet home they're named after one
of the first men
ever to explore antarctica robert falcon
scott
the design hasn't changed much since he
used them
and he was in one just like it right
here on the ross ice shelf
according to his final message had we
lived he said
i should have had a tale to tell of the
hearty hood endurance
and courage of my companions which would
have stirred the heart of every
englishman
that message was discovered after he and
those companions
froze to death
quite a bit colder
[Music]
i'm nervous wearing a nice high wind
speed hat looks like a little nuclear
bomb yep
it was one of those days where bad
weather comes in out of nowhere
and half hour later gotten real flat and
real dark
and uh turn around and come home
i think it looks worse now than it did
when we were in the helicopter
here's the other technical back the
number one priority is that everybody's
safe and everybody comes home
if the helicopter left us i'm pretty
sure we would have been using
tomorrow we try again and hope for a bit
more
sunshine
[Music]
i see the weather is changing
it's due to a um a low pressure area
sitting in the ross sea
and it's dragging some cold air up from
the south pole
with the low cloud coming through into
the position
there's a lot more energy in the wind
this is obvious prediction for
um out on the ross high shelf
i know driving straight into it
the main thing is you just have to be
patient
you can't get antsy about it because
it's not you that makes the decisions
here
syntactic
[Music]
you